Hey Youtubers it's Charlie! This is going
to be my arrow flash crossover part one video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet they did a whole bunch of
legends of tomorrow set up as well as a bunch
of flash stuff because this was the flash
episode part two of the crossover will be
on arrow so the be dealing with some extra
arrow think so expect some Damien Darhk stuff
happening to like there was the self-contained
story setting up Vandal Savage for this episode
but then they each have their continuing storylines
that they have Barry versus Sue they have
team arrow versus Damien Darhk also going
on in the background real quick reminder new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so I'm going
to do top 10 WTF just because there's so much
stuff so I'll try to explain Easter eggs as
I go along starting with number 10 Harrison
wells has a special formula that he's going
to try and use on bearing to push them faster
in the comics there's a formula called velocity
nine that Edward Clariss the very first reverse
flash ends up making to try and make himself
as fast as Jay Garrick he becomes that air
is reverse flash is result of taking the serum
on the TV show it's called velocity six now
Andrew Kreisberg the show runner said that
we would see future iterations of this will
pry get the velocity nine through the back
half of the season but he said the mystery
is going to be who ends up taking the serum
because Jay Garrick is all about keeping it
away from Barry Senior which on a number nine
Jay Garrick comes back you've been gone for
a while saves Harrison wells they have a moment
they're not best friends or anything but we
know that the serum will work if Jay takes
it again so maybe they were fine it Jay takes
morbid defects will last longer I think the
way Jay reacted to this definitely throw some
water on that theory that he might be zoom
he was never my favorite on like the list
of people that could possibly be zoom with
there were some moments in earlier episodes
where you could argue that you know he was
acting really strange like he was never around
when zoom was around but we did see that sequence
with them at the beginning of the season so
I do think that Jay Garrick is not zoom on
the number eight though Patty shoots Harrison
wells this is so great like all my God what
did you do so couple big things happening
here let's unpack one Patty has absolutely
no idea what's going on with her to work team
flash has been doing Joe hasn't told her anything
Caitlin does not know that so when she says
called Joe get his help I'm guessing there's
going to be some ramifications in the second
part of this crossover episode were Patty's
like dude seriously what the hell is going
on that gets into like what's going on with
Barry and Patty like is he going to tell her
his secret what's going on with that is like
a completely separate matter but it all ties
together like people being dishonest with
other characters say things happening with
Iris West knowing about Wally West but not
telling Joe on the number seven enter Vandal
Savage who doesn't look quite as powerful
as he does in the legends of tomorrow trailer
but they do explain it every time he kills
Hawkman in Hawkgirl he gets a little bit stronger
his life force grows as a result of killing
them I don't of this said specifically how
many times he's killed them as of right now
like where we are on the timeline right now
it is private a lot for the legends of tomorrow
that future they're trying to avoid is implied
that Vandal Savage is almost invincible Cisco
barely manages to get a high lander reference
and before they all go to Star city because
Barry feels like this is a magical thing that
they don't know anything about they get there
just in time for Barry to save all over from
Damien Darhk's powers now I guess all of her's
tattoos going to figure in much later maybe
it'll save them from Vandal Savage but the
Constantine tattoo will be important later
this season but I love the way Damien Darhk
reacts to the flash like oh my God this is
so amazing I can't believe this is the greatest
thing ever I totally love with that actors
doing with that character the also slips in
one of my favorite jokes did I know that we
knew the flash I guess yet we know the flash
seems like this are really good for reminding
you which character snow which other characters
secrets not not everybody knows everything
Cisco says that he could come up with a better
name than speedy for she doesn't want to change
it but let me know what you think Cisco would
rename speedy if he had the chance because
she already teased red arrow all of her and
he shut her down hard-core Travis it wouldn't
be that but on my number six WTF enter Merlyn
I love what a theatrical entrance they give
it like the lights flashing aces like surprise
bitches he is the one that explains Vandal
Savage not not a great detail because that's
what Hawkman is doing later he just says this
guy is immortal there's no way you're going
to be able to beat them brick and they need
a lot of help he's just there to let them
know that Vandal Savage has been around for
all of human history he predates the league
of assassins which is itself an ancient culture
on the number five WTF though Hawkman to the
rescue just swoops then grabs can drive takes
off he's been in a bunch of trailers but this
is the first time he is actually been in an
episode if you haven't watched the animated
series there's been a bunch of versions of
Hawkman on the screen like the last live-action
version of the character was played by Michael
Shanks during small Ville that was like the
older version of Hawkman after Hawkgirl had
already died so like imagine much older versions
of these characters be explains that Hawkgirl
has not emerged like her powers have not emerged
in this life yet so she has to do the thing
that Barry did believe in herself let go of
all the bowl should baggage you just jump
off the building Cisco tries like really hard
to hold on to her and I know that they had
this this romance they been teasing between
them but does anybody else feel like this
is a little artificial like they had that
thing with golden glider like he felt really
connected to her within like just like a couple
weeks later he was all over Hawkgirl again
if feels like the only reason that Cisco relationship
exists is to create the drama of this moment
right here give her character a reason to
want to be normal at all the characters have
superhero things that they do like using their
powers fighting villains and then they have
the normal stuff like normal stuff for Barry
is when he sang out with Patty then there's
all the time he's acting as the flash defeating
villains using his powers so I think this
Cisco thing is just meant to be like the normal
stuff for Hawkgirl social of like Hawkgirl
mode then shall have Cisco mode which is just
like being normal with Cisco it is the CW
it's all about love triangles so of course
you have Hawkman we've been lovers across
space and time so they her whole thing with
Cisco there's were she's like me you don't
maybe things are holding me back I need to
embrace my destiny just music she's going
to go off and be alleges a tomorrow it'll
just continue to think of Cisco fondly but
I'm I'm not expecting any crazy romance stuff
between the two of them so if you are not
really down that don't worry at auto that
the gonna be you over the head with it onto
my number four WTF Hawkman explains their
origin story with Vandal Savage so this is
a big change from the comic books so there
but bunch the Easter eggs for Hawkman Vandal
Savage origin stories a comic it's in the
legends of tomorrow stuff that you see the
meteor here getting ready to strike the pyramid
and it looks like it happens around the same
time the Vandal Savage kills Ciara or Hopper
hobby want to think about it for the first
time with one of the nth metal daggers and
I don't know if they're going to call this
mineral nth metal but that's basically what
it is in the comics the reason that Hawkman
Hawkgirl keep getting reincarnated is because
the character name half said is different
from Vandal Savage ends up killing them with
nth metal daggers because of the magical properties
it curses them and begins the cycle of death
and rebirth like this constant reincarnation
so when Vandal Savage says that he has to
like keep killing them to feed his life force
that's like a half set story Vandal Savage's
origin story is all about getting struck with
the meteor right that gives him immortality
and a false his brain makes them supersmart
so what they've done is they combined the
meteor origins of Vandal Savage with the nth
metal murder origins of Hawkman in Hawkgirl
and just tie those together hopefully what
they'll do in the second part of the crossover
is will see a couple more flashbacks but I
think they're get a push a lot of Vandal Savage
storyline to legends of tomorrow and they
did they announced the premier is going to
be Thursday, January 21 I believe so it'll
be flash on Tuesdays arrow on Wednesdays and
and Legends a tomorrow on Thursdays but on
my number three WTF Vandal Savage gets the
staff of Horace this is just a really powerful
artifact there are a number of Horace -related
artifacts in the DC universe there's the I
have Horace which showed up during Constantine's
TV show last year and then there's the claw
of Horace which Hawkman wears the unit mate
maybe not on the show is just part of Egyptian
mythology with gets tied up with Hawkman Hawkgirl
origin stories and for those that are wondering
when Vandal Savage is speaking in a foreign
language that's Egyptian Arabic because the
AMI the base was saying like he's the half
set character so he's from ancient Egypt to
but on my number two WTF Hawkgirl activates
her powers so she has her wings now it looks
like part two of the crossover is what Hawkman
gives her her armor now she's talking to Hawkman
to the episode like she starts to have flashes
of her previous life so they she's gonna unlock
her abilities a little bit faster than say
Barry does because Barry doesn't know what
it's like to be the ultimate version of the
flash yet all Hawkgirl has to do is just remember
her previous life and should be like all I
remember how to fly around the remember how
to do this but finally on my number one WTF
all of her bumps into his son who is not Conor
Hawk I know everyone's wondering about this
because they posted a promo where all of her
like goes up to the house I did a video for
the of the day so we already knew that Oliver
was gonna find out that he had a son but he's
calling him William so there's one of two
things that could be happening it could be
like Thea were like the his name is Thea Dearden
Queen she is the media Dearden speedy from
the comics they could just be messing with
the Conor Hawk name a little bit or this could
just be a completely original character of
the show in yes a lot of you guys have asked
me do I think that the sun or the mother is
going to be the person in the grave at the
end of the season the one that they teased
I don't necessarily think that's going to
be the case I still think it's going to be
there like Diggle work Quentin it's a long
ways off so we'll just have to see like what
happens with this son in the next episode
figure out where all of her's gonna go from
here who might end up happening is is will
just see the child like once a year during
the special crossover episodes your like last
year we discussed the tease they might do
the same thing once a year given the trajectory
of the all of her character it seems like
he try to have a more normal relationship
with it but given his superhero life he's
probably gonna try and keep him away like
look my life is very dangerous I don't want
to get you tied up in this but I would like
to be part of my son's life so let me know
in the comments below what was you guys favorite
moment from the episode and who do you think
is going to be taking the velocity nine formula
in the future what do you think Harrison wells
himself is going to try and take it or the
Jay Garrick cave and take it to try and help
Barry defeat zoom like so much going on in
they have an evening air the promo for episode
nine yet which is when were gonna get to see
Wally West for the first time that's like
a whole other thing walked away till next
week to talk about we're still in the thick
of Hawkman Hawkgirl origins there was a short
promo that they aired during the episode for
legends of tomorrow and had a little bit of
new footage but most of the stuff we've already
seen so like if you watch my trailer video
for that and you pretty much know what's going
on so was can happen next there's some really
big stuff happening Wednesday night there
is a full Batman view Superman trailers dropping
that's gonna be like way late in the night
so I might finish my arrow video before that
posts so generally just be aware that a bunch
of stuff is going to be dropping tomorrow
night you as you follow me on twitter and
Facebook I'll be posting updates about when
videos are coming you can click here for my
Batman v Superman teaser video and here for
the legends of Tomorrow trailer thank you
so much for watching, everybody let's high
five and I'll see you tonight!